and joining us now the speaker of the
house nancy pelosi
madam speaker welcome back to fox news
sunday my pleasure to be with you good
morning chris
president trump says while you and
congressional democrats were pushing
your agenda he acted yesterday to help
people
in need take a look nancy pelosi and
chuck schumer have chosen to hold this
vital assistance hostage
on behalf of very extreme partisan
demands and
the radical left democrats said we just
can't do that
however it came about about and i know
you don't like the executive action
won't millions of americans now get some
extended
federal unemployment relief and some
protection
from evictions get that now rather than
getting nothing at all
no in fact what the president did is i
agree with the republican senator said
it was
unconstitutional slop while it has the
illusion
of saying we're going to have a
moratorium on evictions it says
i'm going to ask you the folks in charge
to study
if that's feasible one he says he's
going to do the
the uh payroll tax what he's doing is
undermining
social security and medicare so these
are
illusions and they really do not what he
calls in our bill unnecessary
let's just review the difference first
of all
millions of children in our country are
food insecure
our bill addresses that with tens of
billions of dollars
feed the children the republican bill
has
250 000 dollars
while our bill addresses those who are
and
on the brink of eviction we use the the
numbers from the princeton
eviction lab and the low-income housing
coalition
to show how many people will be evicted
and what their needs are
and that comes to could come to tens of
billions of dollars
the republican bill has nothing this
being a sunday morning
i just recall a prayer that says
pray for those who are hungry pray
harder for those
who will not feed them pray for those
who are homeless pray harder for those
who will not give them shelter
pray for those who are sick and lonely
pray harder
for those who will not give them comfort
but what the president did does not
address
schools all of the issues that are
contained
in the legislation we can go through
that but you said give short answers
but speaker i understand that the
president's executive action doesn't do
all the things you want but but
having no bill at all not coming to any
agreement wasn't going to
provide any of the things that you want
either you're known as a mass
master negotiator but didn't you mess
this one up because
you talk about all the things that the
president's bill
let me just finish if i may speaker uh
now
because there's no deal at all cities
and states won't get any money
there's no money for the post office
there's no money
for hospitals there's no money for state
boards of election uh
you knew that the president was
threatening to take this executive
action
i understand that you weren't going to
get everything you wanted and didn't get
any everything you wanted but should you
have cut a deal
and are you ready to go back into talks
to try to come up with a fuller package
well clearly you don't have an
understanding of what is happening here
both in the weakness of the president's
executive orders which don't give the
money
to enhance benefit but puts a
complicated formula there which
will take a while if at all to
accomplish to put money in the pockets
of the american people
what we have said we're going to honor
our heroes state and local
healthcare workers etc first responders
teachers and the rest
and that's part of our argument is how
much
are they willing to do secondly we're
going to stop the uh
me to finish they're going to uh let's
open our economy
by addressing addressing the virus which
the president
has ignored for months now to do the
right thing
scientifically based and third let's put
money in the pockets of the american
people
so what the president did doesn't even
accomplish
what he sets out to do in the categories
he did but we said to them
we'll come down a trillion you go up a
trillion
meet us halfway and we'll be able to
have an agreement that meets the needs
of the american people i understand
speaker but the point i'm trying to
i'm trying to to make is you
they were offering 150 billion dollars
for cities and states you wanted 900
billion
the result of no deal is that the states
and cities which we all agree
do need some money are going to get
nothing i i guess the question is
i'm not saying it's all your fault any
more than it's all the republicans fault
but the failure to make a deal is going
to result in a lot of people and a lot
of entities that were in need
ending up with nothing well how do you
how do you
justify tens of billions of dollars to
feed the hungry
to 250 thousand dollars you understand
how far apart we are just by that
example
let's bring all of that together you
contend that they're putting up money
for
elections no no you contend they're
helping with the post office
none of that is in their bill so when
you look at the amounts that are in
their bill
it doesn't have any of that our bill
does
but let's put it this way we have to
reach an agreement
children are food insecure families are
at the risk of being
evicted the virus is moving like a
freight train even though the president
once has ignored and delayed and
distorted what that is
something's wrong when you look at those
executive orders
either the kindest thing i could say is
he doesn't know
what he's talking about or something's
wrong there something's very very wrong
there so to characterize
them as even accomplishing what they set
out to do
as something that is that would take the
place of an agreement
is just not so
you suggested that president trump does
not have the
legal authority to do what he did
yesterday
are you talking about going to court
because if you do you must know
that the practical effect with of that
would be if you're successful
that you would be blocking i know you'd
think that they should be six hundred
dollars rather than four hundred dollars
but you would be blocking if you were
successful
uh the millions of unemployed workers
from getting any federal benefit
well two things first of all your last
point what the president put forth was a
complicated formula
which said that the states should put up
25 percent of the money the states don't
have the money to do that
they have expenses from the corona virus
they have
lost revenue from shelter in place and
the the the fact that people are not
being able to
go out and spend money and inject demand
into the economy as they would normally
but apart from that
the the constitutionality of that is a
different question
right now we need to come to agreement
we've got to meet halfway we've got to
make do the best we can for the american
people
but that what they're putting forth does
not meet that standard
it could it could and we care so much
about the fact that people are in need
our children want to go to school our
parents want them to go
as a grandmother and a mom i understand
the angst that is with that but what the
president didn't do anything about that
so the president's uh meager
weak and unconstitutional actions
further
demand that we have an agreement and any
constitutional question
is a separate issue
speaker i wanted to get two questions in
if you do resume talks and you say you
want to
and i'm not saying that this is all on
you as opposed to the republicans but
why do we should we expect the talks
will be
any more successful than the last two
weeks that went nowhere
would the democrats be willing to be
more flexible
well we said we would we come down a
trillion now
it doesn't mean that we have things in
there that we would cut out
it means that we could talk about how
long
our provisions would be in effect so we
can take things down
instead of the end of september of next
year a shorter period of time
and we'll revisit all of it next year
anyway so
by changing some of the timing we can
come down
but by and large what we have in the
bill addresses the needs of the american
people
and and we have just and part of the
time it has taken for us to go back and
forth
is to demonstrate to the republican
negotiators
the justification the documentation
of what it means in terms of what we
need for feeding the hungry what we need
for
helping people on the verge of eviction
what we need for schools
speaker i i i understand all that i got
one last question i'd like to get in
in the time on a completely different
subject the intelligence community
came out with a report this week that
says
that the russians are taking their words
a range of measures to undercut joe
biden
and to help president trump get
re-elected but they also said that china
and iran
uh very much want to see the president
defeated
are you worried about foreign
interference from both sides
no in fact what i'm concerned about
uh in the intelligence report and we
have leader schumer
excuse me schumer and i uh chairman
schiff and vice chairman whatever they
call in the senate
warner have written to say you have to
release the information not sources and
methods
but the american people need to know
what the russians
are doing in this case and the american
people believe that they
should decide who the next president is
not vladimir putin
they try to blanket it with the chinese
they said prefer
biden over we don't know that but that's
what they're saying but they're not
really getting involved
in the presidential election i've been a
critic of china for over 30 years i take
notes
second place to no one on my criticism
of china but they
for them to to give some equivalence is
not
right it doesn't really tell the story
but
as long as they tell the whole story
about russia
then they can hide it any way they want
but the american people need to know
this is our sacred right this is our
elections
and in every way we must make sure the
american people
have removed obstacles of participation
and obstacles
uh in terms of intelligence to make sure
they know what is at stake
speaker in the hopes of uh negotiations
i'm going to put
take you off the stage and put secretary
mnuchin
on so he gets to to talk as well thank
you so much thank you for your time
always good to talk with you
my pleasure thank you chris